[Music]
good morning guys I just woke up and I
thought you know what let's do another
get ready with me with you guys
yesterday I put my hair up in double
braids and as you can see they've been
slept in so usually I have I did this
hairstyle where it looks really curly
and really wavy and stuff and people
really like how that looks and
everyone's always asking me how I get I
achieved that look because they think I
actually curl it but I don't I put it in
double braids and then I take out the
braids and then I put some product in it
and then I make it work somehow I don't
know sometimes I'm like wow this is way
too frizzy but we're gonna see if we can
achieve that look today no one's home
okay see had to leave so I thought let's
do a video so first I'm gonna go wash my
face and then we're gonna start to see
if we could do anything with this hair
or maybe I might do my makeup first I
don't know probably makeup first so you
guys don't have to look at this the
whole time alright since I have a free
day today and I have to worry about
hurrying up and getting ready I'm gonna
actually put a mask on somebody's this
exfoliating mask base to the wetsuit and
then put this on my head so my hair or
like whatever taking a little hairs I
have can stay out of my face
please look up keep this thing is my
supposed to took my ears behind it or
I'll let them stick out I don't know
sometimes I do it this way sometimes the
other way let's wash the face okay I use
this Marad I don't know how to pronounce
this but this is the thing that I use to
wash my face
it's an exfoliating cleanser but you
know what if this is an exfoliating mask
is that too much exfoliation because you
know what I have so many products for
like beauty products and stuff and my
day to day is usually hectic and I don't
even have a chance to like use all these
like masks and stuff and and it's either
I don't have time or I get really lazy
at the end of the day because I'm
already really tired from a whole long
day of doing things I'm running around
so I'll just like take off my makeup
with my magic eraser which is amazing
and I love it
so I usually do that and then kind of
like rinse off a little bit and then put
on my like nighttime stuff and call it a
day I never use masks but today we're
gonna use this one
I just had to rinse my face because I
had ayah boogers and drawl and still
fonts out on my face this thing is so
huge like what's the point I don't know
what it's cute I need to pull up my
phone and Google how long am I supposed
to use this and it came with this cute
little brush and I just don't I don't
like doing things the wrong way so give
me a second how do you use this thing
says it's an in shower mask it literally
says an in shower washed off the mask
looks like I'm not using that I forgot
when I'm read conduit I got rid of all
my stuff
hey good at this one I have a pure clay
mask you know what I don't care if it
does it's an inch our mask I'm using it
now it's like a fishtail I don't know
you could say look it's like oops I cut
tool into it how you're supposed to put
a mask who knows no one knows we just
all pretend we know what we're doing so
during my day time I don't have like
I'll have a meeting to go to or any
appointments I booked cuz that's really
my day to day but later tonight though I
do have to do something that's to meet
up with the girls because we are working
on a project you guys will find out soon
enough
who says I can't show up to a meeting
with my girlfriend's looking good stay a
while since I talked to you guys and
there were a couple weeks where should
we actually didn't upload anything to
our channel and that's cuz we've just
been going through a lot
Casey and I
I recently did a video game video for
you guys and then now like this is not
this is actually like a video or I'm
like eggs
let's connect guys last time we really
truly connected was when I did my dads
on that video and that was so beautiful
and then I already said this in another
video but you guys responded to that
with so much love and support and I was
overwhelmed because I was like oh my
goodness and there were so many people
that sent me messages and said like oh
my gosh right I'm so glad you talked
about this like I don't feel so alone
cuz I'm going through a lot too and I'm
like wow plus not only did you guys not
feel alone I didn't feel alone because
I've been going through this practically
alone I mean I do have like my family
and friends but it's just they're not
like it's just really hard because
besides my sister is like no one else
knows what it really feels like and I
know just felt really nice to to connect
with you guys so that was cool now we're
gonna set the timer for 10 min oh don't
know what should we talk about in the
meantime I guess I can share with us for
our channel we are having a new editor
so Thank You Antoine he also works with
JK he's editing this video and he has
been doing a great job already and let
us know in the comments like do you guys
like Antoine's
editing is he doing a great job I'm sure
he is let him know on the personal side
he's been a lot going on like a lot but
it's just unfortunate that this is the
kind of stuff that it's like oh yeah we
kind of
I gotta keep it to ourselves but I just
wanted to at least share the fact that
there's a lot that's been going on or
also positive endings to situations and
no biggie is just life life is tough no
matter what like if you guys are going
through something right now just know it
will pass you will be good the universe
loves you and you just have to trust
that the universe is always having your
best interest in mind even though there
might be moments that you feel like why
the heck is this happening to me or why
do things turn out this way
but you just have to trust that things
are happening the way they're happening
because that's the way they're meant to
be happening it's not a bad thing it's a
good thing you just have to have faith
and I know this all sounds very like
hippy dippy like like very cryptic and
stuff but I don't know I feel like
that's a message in my heart that I
needed to share and hopefully I know it
impacts someone out there that you might
need to hear it rough couple of weeks
maybe about a month it's been really
crazy overall things are fine it's good
this mask feels very soothing it's made
out of ginseng that's a whole stool on
sue but that's the actual ingredient
that they use in this mask and that's
the reason why it's so like rejuvenating
and great for your skin it rained
yesterday
alright timers done brush my teeth in
between
now let's circle
[Music]
okay anyway they want this to be on
showers thanks for everybody else
[Music]
one time a couple years ago I'm washing
my face and then it just got so
frustrated with the water dripping down
to my elbows and even if I'm not wearing
a long sleeve like it's still annoying
like your entire arm gets wet and so I'm
like there has to be a better way so I
went up to Casey I'm like easy there
needs to be an invention where you could
just put on these like silicone kind of
like things that just trap the water
like this and then so when you're
washing your hands you could just like
leave it up to your wrists or whatever
because if it's down here you're still
getting your entire arm wet but like if
it's like right here you're just like
washing your hands and it traps
everything and you can't like run down
your hand those things would sell like
hotcakes cuz people know that that
annoying thing that like your entire arm
has to get wet when you wash your face
like why why does it why is that I think
what am i washing my face wrong people I
even went so far as to the research and
see if this invention existed and I came
empty-handed so I don't know this
doesn't make this and in cases like why
don't you invent it you have the idea
you already see it in your head why
don't you go and lie find a manufacturer
so they can make it for you and I was
just like listen that's a lot of work so
my face is nice and clean it feels fresh
so it was my mouth it's nice and clean
let's beautify this face this is nice
and clean another the word I couldn't
think of when I was describing the
freaking hand thingy it was like like a
hand like a wrist too - so what are you
guys up to today what are you going to
be doing since I already showed you my
beauty the skincare routine thing I'm
the thing that we're gonna do later
today I wish I could talk to you guys
more about it and I really wish I could
tell you the stuff I was talking about
earlier because man that stuff did you
do see but anyway that's my mom so I've
always had these like internal like like
$0.06 kind of vibes like my gut feelings
are always very strong some people might
call that intuition
other people might call it being
connected to energy stuff I don't know
it sounds so oh my gosh I'm saying this
out loud and it sounds so funny it's
kind of like people who would live their
lives through horoscopes and like that's
like whatever their hose of course cope
says for that that day or that week or
whatever like that's their only doing
whatever that says they're like they
really believe in psychics this is how
crazy this sounds but trust me I'm not
that crazy I'm just like I just don't
really like I said it's going through a
lot a lot of meditating stuff if you
guys watch hey [ __ ] you will know that
I have a trip coming up because I'm
filming this before my trip I'm super
excited for that trip because during
that trip I really I'm gonna do a lot of
like self-discovery I'm gonna actually
do a workbook that my friend Shan has
created so she wrote this book called
game of desire and in that book she gave
details how she got these six girls and
there they all come from like different
walks of life like different sexual
orientations and all that stuff they
were just learning about themselves and
like she's really like guiding you
mainly for women negating women to to
know how to really get themselves out
there in the dating world yeah like I'm
married like why do I need to worry
about that stuff but she actually talks
a lot about like just like interpersonal
relationship stuff and like even like
within yourself stuff like
self-discovery things and like I said I
know this sounds like some hippie stuff
but I really am at that age I'm about to
turn 30 I
at that age where I'm like really trying
to be like Who am I I didn't know myself
what kind of what kind of partner in my
what kind of friend am i what kind of
like mother am I you know like all these
well these deep questions that I've
never bothered to ask myself and really
look like take a look inside within
myself right I'm taking a trip to Bora
Bora for my birthday and it's actually a
solo trip and I know to some people it
sounds like scary or really sad to take
like a trip all alone especially during
your birthday / Thanksgiving if a lot of
people might be like oh that's so sad
why would you ever do that or oh my gosh
that's so scary why would you ever do
that but for me it's like oh my gosh I
finally get to do that just because I've
always always always always always
wanted to take a solo trip not just like
a solo trip just anywhere right so like
for the last 10 years ever since I saw
the movie couples retreat back in 2009 I
have been dying and dreaming about going
to Bora Bora because that's where they
filmed the movie and they like I
remember seeing those over the water
bungalows for the first time and I was
just like oh my god I need to be there
at some point in my life that needs to
happen and I'm just so excited and I'm
so happy that I finally get to make it
happen now and for like such a big
occasion to like you know your 30th
birthday is pretty important yeah and
then Casey was really sweet and
supportive because I was really
contemplating like like no like you know
that we'll just the whole like upcoming
Thanksgiving week it's Isaac's time off
from school we could finally spend a
whole week straight with like some
family time and so yeah I was just
really concerned about that and then
also like you know the house situation
should we really be spending money on a
trip like that
probably not
and then not just that but it's like oh
but you know okay fine like if I am
gonna take a solo trip for my birthday
does it have to be Bora Bora I was like
battling these internal thoughts right I
were and then I was telling Casey about
them too where I'm like well it doesn't
have to be Barbara it could just go to
Hawaii or something cuz my happy place
is a beach like any time
I'm extremely overwhelmed and I just
need to like close my eyes and escape
somewhere it's always the beach always
Casey was just really like you know what
no matter where you go it's not gonna be
horrible and it's just not gonna be what
you've been dreaming of so you should
just take that trip and I was just like
oh my God thank you so much okay I
booked it over the years even just
randomly on my weather app on my phone I
always have Bora Bora there and if I'm
always checking the weather here like or
wherever I am like you know because we
travel a lot I'm always taking a peek at
with for Boras weather like so I've
literally been dying and dreaming to go
there so that's gonna be exciting and
then during that time that I'm gone the
boys are gonna go camping and spending
like some quality father-son time so
that's gonna be pretty nice for them you
know I had Isaac at 17 I've been in a
relationship ever since I was 16 I've
been in a relationship so it's only like
one or two months in between
relationships yeah like I'm a serial
monogamist person so I just never gotten
some like a long time and I'm not saying
that I'm taking this week and I'm all of
a sudden I'm divorced no it's just like
I've just never experienced a whole week
by myself like that just never happened
because I really just want to experience
like being solo I'm actually gonna turn
off my phone
I'll only turn it on for photos here and
there and we'll take the GoPro just a
document here and there but I really
don't plan on being connected anywhere
and then I have to
practicing to not be friendly because I
don't know how to not be friendly and I
really don't want strangers to talk to
me I don't know how I'm gonna navigate
that because I'm just such a social
person have you guys ever taking the
solo trip anywhere cuz we're in South
Korea I met this girl who she's married
and she only does solo trips around the
world and I was like whoa that's so cool
social that's like her therapy like she
travels everywhere all alone
so like wow that's so cool yeah I don't
know have you guys ever taken silla term
especially women I want to know like
have any of you girls ever done a
completely solo trip and it's one thing
to to like be alone while you're
traveling to go meet up with someone
that's not what I'm talkin about cuz
I've done that a lot and that's not what
I mean oh maybe that's why I actually
want to take a complete solo trip that's
just like the light bulb turned on in my
head because when I was little my mom
used to send me to Mexico for the summer
but I used to go an airplane alone so at
one point I think she told me like they
the first time I ever went on a plane
alone I was like five years old or
something or between two or five I
forgot completely alone and that was the
first of many solo airplane rides and
yeah like that just I got really
comfortable with traveling all by myself
and if you guys don't know what happens
when a child travels by themselves it's
they have this program like airlines
have these programs where the flight
attendant keeps an eye on you and you
have like this really bright like badge
on you that says unaccompanied minor
like your parent dropped you off at the
gate and then from there on like there's
an applied attendant that takes care of
you make sure that you're okay and then
once you land the airline staff makes
sure that they hand you off to the
Guardian that's supposed to be picking
you up so that's the way it works so I
I've experienced just being in another
plane all by myself
but I've just always wanted a solo trip
Isaac got to experience flying alone for
the first time or for like the only time
when we were getting married so he flew
from LA to Dallas to go meet up with the
Chan clan and then from Dallas they were
gonna go to to Paris together and they
kind of like made me relive my childhood
a little bit through him because I'm
like ah that's so cute I remember going
on the plane on one myself
you know even though I do this like
beauty product stuff underneath my
makeup it kind of makes me go back a
little weird maybe I should feel like a
primer I forgot to put a primer this
time well okay I had to close this door
because sometimes like when I put my
powder on and stuff and the different
lighting coming from the side I ended up
putting like too much on one side
because the lighting is off but that's I
actually got through vetting vanity legs
to meet the lighting really nice and
even you know what I should do one of
these days I should look up the makeup
tutorial and just follow that I don't
look anything up I don't try to discover
any mewn techniques I just continue to
do the makeup the way that I've learned
how to do it and that's it actually I'll
show you there's my drawer I have so
much makeup in here alright so look I
bought lashes for the first time
recently I have no idea how to put them
on you guys are gonna see me try these
on all these different eyeshadows all
that stuff but they're always like
generally the same colors honestly only
have these because these things were
gifted to me so like oh this has been my
most favorite palette I've been using so
far and it's by a color pop and so cute
all these cute colors and then
I have this white tarp this is like for
the face yeah I end up using these for
eye shadows I think they might be for
the face but whatever they smell like
chocolate to this this thing smells
really good and then yeah I still have
my old brush that for some reason I just
can't get rid of I should probably throw
it away but I still can't get rid of it
I've only ever worn at last just once
and that was for Beauty event thing that
they actually glam me up but I don't
know whenever we travel sometimes I need
like either me or can see that we need
allergy pills I bought this in Aruba but
yeah that's my makeup drawer it was
actually pretty much cleared out up
until a few months ago and then I went
to more events and then they more beauty
events and then they just kept giving me
more stuff the downside of having big
eyes
you had a whole bunch of fuzzy things in
your eyes like I said I just wing it
let's see what I come up with actually I
look at my outfit and then I do my
eyeshadow but this time I'm gonna do it
backwards because I'm a rebel like that
I have so many friends that do makeup
for a living I've never sat down with
any of them like alright girlfriend
teach me I should do that Wednesday's to
be honest this is pure laziness people
tell me like oh I look like I do your
makeup that looks so natural and I'm
like thank you I got the yellow base
it's a wild soul I know my girls usually
are like makeup artists and stuff they
usually do like the face makeup blast
because if you do like a crazy look like
this I put the whole bunch of color and
then it falls down on your cheeks that's
that's your fault right because you
should have been doing your makeup base
after I'm pretty sure that's gonna be
the case
for me today but it's okay I just don't
know how to do my makeup if I don't do
my face stuff first there's some reason
that's like the first step I learned and
that's just the first step I've kept all
right so that's what we got so far
oh man I probably should have gotten a
coffee before I started doing all this
so early but hey all right
I never learned how to properly blend so
these days that I've been getting more
adventurous and doing more eyeshadow
books I've been like trying to figure
out how to blend it a little bit better
yeah see and then I use the same brush
for everything to like I don't know what
I'm doing guys yeah these colors are
really pretty and then I got this pimple
bone on here so this Scylla we got so
far I think I like it better in person
on camera does it look that good
wait why am i doing makeup so early in
the morning I only think - is it I'm
getting ready or if I'm cooking or
anything I gotta put my stuff away right
away when I'm done using it because then
it's not there's like this gigantic mess
and I get overwhelmed and I don't want
to deal with it then I have to do it as
I go
I like highlighter like right in the
inner corners I might put a little bit
of the pink but I'm telling you guys
I've been so stressed my face never
breaks out but every game I have another
one here that's kind of going away I'm
like damn I'm just gonna look like this
all day and they're by time I see the
girls oh well I have this setting spray
which is also a SPF someone be using
this hopefully my makeup can hold up for
the rest of the day
[Music]
we're putting these on wish me luck
I literally do not know how to do this
I've seen people do something like this
how do you women do this I have no idea
how how you won't stay oMG I think I got
it
Dana's inner corner is poking that crap
out of my eye all right I got these bad
boys on it can't believe practically 30
and this is the very first time I've
ever played on fake eyelashes mascara
time well this is weird I never put
mascara on lashes on before like fake
lashes I just this this feels weird
this is cool I'm like it just might be
wearing these lashes from now on and
when I film I'm supposed to eyeliner on
top of this now I don't know I'm too
lazy for that so I'm not doing that
all right my face is complete the lashes
look great
looks cool now the crew onto the hair
[Music]
all right moment of truth see they come
up nice and curly and pretty
sometimes I I want to leave the part
down the middle like this but never been
brave enough to do it look how pretty
these curls are and I don't have to
waste like my time sitting here with the
curling iron because I've tried a
million times and that's actually a
video I really do want to make for you
guys is showing you all of the curly
products that I have like the the hair
tools and I have to make my hair curly I
have so many because I have always
wanted to just just have curly hair look
and I always end up buying tools that
supposedly make it easier but they
really don't because I end up having
these curls for I couldn't like I'll
have it for today and then one more day
before I wash my hair again sometimes if
things are really hectic I'll have them
for two more days but yeah I like the
next day the curls kind of calm down and
they look they don't look at it's like
little luminous I like it see how easy
that is I just take out my braids i will
use anti-frizz in my braids so once I
take them out alright in my hair once I
take out the braids let me get a little
less frizzy since I did sleep with the
braids in I'm gonna pick out an outfit
now to complete this look and we can end
this video cuz you guys have seen me get
really long enough
use the closet go with this babies wear
some jeans call it a day
alright now what do we think I mean I
don't really I'm not really like super
dressed up dressing dressed up but it's
okay it does a trick another thing I
like to do with my hair is bobby pin it
to the side like so
now let's accessorize I like because
what they get heavy oh look how pretty I
got these from my friend Stacy's new
jewelry shop her shop is called black a
jewel calm this bracelet that I'm
wearing is also from there and she also
gave me this really cute bracelet I did
shot it on my stories too so you see my
stories you already know all of this
alright I got this necklace put on from
also her jewelry shop which I really
love
it's super cute this is this is my look
this is what I've done and this is the
camera you guys are living in right now
but yeah thank you guys so much for
being here with me while I got ready
this morning and by now it's already not
that early in the morning thank you guys
I love you comment down below any other
suggestions kind of videos you guys
would like to see me do I mean let me
know how I did on my makeup I am
actually very proud of myself with these
lashes I think I did pretty damn good
the hair came out great I look fabulous
thank you
[Music]